Speaker 1: Bill Barr, Donald Trump's former
attorney general, continues to attack his
former boss. You may remember that last week
Bill Barr commented on the indictment having to
do with the alleged mishandling of classified
documents when he went on Fox News Sunday and
said that if even half of the indictment is
true, then Trump is toast. He also rebuked
Trump's legal team's claims that the matter
should fall under the Presidential Records Act
rather than the Espionage Act in full. Bill
Barr said that if even half of it is true,
then he is toast. I mean, it's a pretty it's
a very detailed indictment and it's very,
very damning. And these were big statements, of
course, because of who they were coming from,
the top prosecutor in the Trump administration
for a time, Bill Barr. Trump then responded to
Bill Barr statements by calling him a gutless
pig. Well, fast forward to this weekend. This
past weekend, when Bill Barr was on Face the
Nation on CBS, and Barr is actually stepping
up the criticism. He's not backing down. He's now
calling Trump a consummate narcissist who will put
his own interests, his own ego above everything
else. He also called Trump a defiant nine year old
kid and a fundamentally flawed person who engages
in reckless conduct. So there's a couple of clips
I want to play for you from this interview. The
first has to do with the legal arguments. Barr
decimates the idea that Trump had the right
to take the records under the Presidential
Records Act and could simply unilaterally just
classify them without going through a process,
telepathically or otherwise. Bill Barr says
that he had absolutely no right to do that,
and he had no right to possess the documents.
Speaker 3: The legal theory by which he gets
to take battle plans and sensitive national
security information as his personal papers
is absurd. It's just as wacky as the legal
doctrine they came up with. You know, having
the vice president unilaterally determine who won
the election. The whole purpose of the statute,
the Presidential Records Act, is was to stop
presidents from taking official documents out of
the White House. It was passed after Watergate.
That's the whole purpose of it. And therefore,
it restricted what a president can take. It
says it's purely private. That had nothing
to do with the deliberations of government policy.
Obviously, these documents are not purely private.
It's obvious. And they're not even now arguing
that it's purely private. What they're saying
is the president just has sweeping discretion to
say they are, even though they squarely don't fall
within the definition. It's an absurd argument.
Speaker 1: So Barr says it. The Presidential
Records Act was meant to restrict the rights
of presidents, not to grant them immunity or
give them more power. And it's not even
relevant to this case because this has
to do with national secrets, not just Trump's
daily diary, anything innocuous. So it's not
something that would fall under the Presidential
Records Act. This falls under the Espionage Act.
And then we get into the fun part. This is when
Bill Barr talks about the possibility of Trump
becoming the nominee and becoming president
again and the impact that that would have
on the country. Let's take a look at this.
Speaker 3: Trump, as you know, has many good
qualities, and he accomplished some good things.
But the fact of the matter is he is a consummate
narcissist and he constantly engages in reckless
conduct that that puts his political followers at
risk and the conservative and Republican agenda
at risk when he put the country at risk if he was
in the White House again, he will always put
his own interests and gratifying his own ego
ahead of everything else, including the country's
interests. There's no question about it. This is a
perfect example of that. He's like, you know, he's
like a nine year old. A defiant nine year old kid
is always pushing the glass toward the edge of the
table, defying his parents to stop him from doing
it. It's a means of self-assertion and exerting
his dominance over other people. And he's a very
petty individual who will always put his interests
ahead of the country's, his personal gratification
of his, you know, of his ego. But our country,
our country can't, you know, can't be a therapy
session for, you know, a troubled man like this.
Speaker 1: Blistering words there from Bill Barr.
But let's put it all into perspective. Barr was
also critical of Donald Trump when it came to
January 6th and the allegations of voter fraud in
the 2020 election. He famously would not go along
with the plan to try to overturn the election
results. And he resigned a few weeks before
the end of the Trump administration. But then. He
was asked if he'd vote for Trump over a Democrat,
and he actually said yes, that the threat of
Donald Trump is not greater than the threat
of a progressive being put into power. So Barr
believes that Trump is like a nine year old child.
He believes that he's a cosmic narcissist.
He believes that he's someone who puts his
own interests in front of the country, someone
who is wrong on the law, wrong on the morals,
someone who is presumably guilty of crimes. And
yet Barr thinks that that guy is a better vote
than boring old Joe Biden or someone else who is
in the Democratic Party because of, I don't know,
socialism or inflation or something like
that. So I believe it's useful to bring
up Bill Barr statements when arguing these
issues specifically with Trump supporters,
because if you're in a discussion about classified
documents and you can effectively bring up someone
who works in the Trump administration to rebuke
Trump's own talking points, I think that that can
actually maybe get you somewhere, right, Because
this is someone who actually was an ally of Trump
who is just not willing to stand with him when
it comes to this very issue. But that doesn't
mean that we're really rehabilitating William
Barr here. It doesn't mean that we can point
to him as someone who is morally upstanding and
right about other things. It's really just like
the same analysis that we have when it comes to
George W Bush, because Bush from time to time will
criticize Donald Trump. And we acknowledge that
Bush is capable of making coherent points when it
comes to the damage that Donald Trump is doing to
the country, while not overlooking the damage that
George W Bush did to the country. When it comes
to the needless wars, when it comes to the war,
criminality and everything else that he did
during his eight years. So that's Bill Barr
for you. Absolutely. He's no hero or anything
like that, but he is someone that maybe you can
bring up when it comes to this conversation
about mishandling of classified documents,
the fact that even Trump's own former A.G. is
not standing by him when it comes to this issue.
Let's go to a break and we'll be back with much
more of the David Pacman Show right after this.